333 left
oh gee on him
tomorrow
106 102 135 to go
[Applause]
derozan
stepping over
short ball rebound
here's levine trying to burn some clock
up ahead derozan
[Applause]
out there and spark
this team victory
tony bradley jr
what about stops now the offense
not coming up big for you your defense
has to
frozen fading and getting
these guys are too talented to just lay
down and give up they've got pieces now
as compared to years past
85
on the six minutes left four-point game
derozan in his wheelhouse
coaches do an excellent job out of the
timeouts kind of getting
the play they want that time demar
derozan able to have
tears green a mctearan's man on
the bulls will take time off it there's
still 15 seconds difference shot clock
game clock don't have to follow but he
got to get a stop derozan
and watch what derozan does
penetrates devastates off the glass
that's the next one to talk so they've
got five minutes to continue with this
kind of energy
as they bring back derozan and
immediately scores
boy's looking for their 18th win of the
year they're second in the east
demar derozan corner the key left side
right hand
automatic when he gets there
automatically draw up something they
know they have to be clean the rest of
the way
[Music]
[Applause]
look at the bucket that got the lead
just step in
elevate over lebron james and he's
feeling it
[Applause]
what an effort
tonight minus his sidekick zach levine
this guy is
incredible it really is
his focus
derozan
around the edge that's money and capella
was all over him too that's money i mean
that's his sweet spot yeah
sabonis
missed it
oh you got to get the rebound
no
jerosa ford
they're going to play it out too they're
not
[Applause]
somehow he's able to make it well
defended
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and derozan makes it a one-point game
[Music]
oh wow and one abdia can't believe it
went with his hands up
his last in the nba in challenges
and west is making a decision now he
doesn't want to challenge it
pat delaney speaking with wesson jr
here's derozan no kobe white two derozan
two seconds in the corner for
[Applause]
you talk about
cool common collected he was definitely
behind a three-point line
that's a three yeah
[Applause]
wow
wow wow wow derozan
you talk about having an all nba type
year
that dude is a is a
cold-hearted
killer
caruso running with four starters
[Applause]
derozan
oh he had a mission and he just put it
down
i would always say big time players make
big time plays he's going to get in
there and there's the foul by okoro and
he's just strong enough